joining us now is Branson's mayor care
and best madam mayor first our
condolences to all of you here in this
community you're from here we've been
here over 50 years or 50 years I believe
at this point what of the last 36 hours
been like for you it's been a roller
coaster it's been a roller coaster of
emotion you know anytime you hear that
there's a loss of life it touches your
community and you know we're community
of resilience and we are all about
taking care of our citizens but I think
what makes us very unique is we're all
about taking care of strangers - it's
what's made us who we are we've been
that way since I think beginning of time
and so and when you come here the
experience that you get is that we love
on you no matter whether you're here as
a citizen or you're here as someone that
we've never met before
how are the citizens though coping they
may not have known all of these people
but this is still a tragedy that has
engulfed this community our community is
very heartbroken I mean if you look on
social media you will see a very common
thread and that is a heartbreak you know
we care very much about those that live
around us but we care very much about
anyone who enters this city I know that
you knew the driver of the vehicle Bob
some people said he was the mayor in
some ways of this town what can you tell
us about him you know
Bob when he would walk into a room he
would light a room up you know he lit
the room up with a smile he lit the room
up with his personality he didn't even
have to say anything everybody was
always drawn to Bob just a a real pillar
in the community just salt of the earth
he never met a stranger he loved
everyone and he's going to be sorely
missed in our community I'm not sure if
he's certain if you've spoken with his
family at all how are they coping today
you know it's it's it's tough you know
when you when you lose someone that is
so near and dear to your heart how do
you how do you make that a good
it's never never easy you were telling
me before we started here that you were
just out on the duck boats with your
family do you look at the duck boats
differently now after what happened on
Thursday you know growing up the duck
boats have always been
excuse me one of our favorite things to
do you know as businesses we take our
employees there and it was always so
great so you know after a tragedy like
this you start thinking of things
different you know after 9/11 when I
flew I would never get on a plane again
and and and fly the same way so I'm sure
as you know people get on the boats I'm
sure their attitudes will change
somewhat I think people will be more
safety conscious when they get on I know
I will do you think the boats still
belong though here in Branson Missouri I
know there calls for some of the safety
changes you know I think it's really
early in the investigation stage and
I'll be looking forward to what the NTSB
in the Coast Guard come up with you know
there may be some safety changes that
need to be made
senator blunt and Senator McCaskill were
here yesterday we were talking about you
know what we could do to improve that I
think it's too early to make that
decision but I think as time goes on I
think that's something that that not
just here but across America because
these are not just unique to Branson
madam mayor we appreciate the time thank
you Anthony and Michelle we'll send it
back to you now Jacobson as the mayor
said it's heartbreaking and
heartbreaking to watch Tia Coleman that
mother with lost three kids I don't know
how she can even talk about what
happened I can't imagine either and I
think about really the question whether
or not this singular boat or any boat
its size in that weather could have
prevented this from happening we shall
certainly see in the coming year